feliz mañana Raúl bueno contarle que
Pedro Castillo como se lo señaló Fue
trasladado en un helicóptero a la base
de la hiroes es un penal barradío esto
funciona como cárcel para los
expresidentes de este país y justamente
ahí también purga condena el
expresidente Alberto fujimori fuente de
policiales señalan que Pedro Castillo
durmió poco y Tuvo una noche una noche
larga y en verdad razón no le falta
porque lo que se le viene es un futuro
legal muy complicado Por lo pronto los
magistrados del tribunal constitucional
han dicho que van a acusar a Pedro
Castillo por quebrar el orden
constitucional lo magistrados señalan
que el ex gobernante cometió abuso de
autoridad al cerrar el parlamento sin un
sustento legal y en paralelo la fiscalía
ha emprendido procesos penales por los
delitos de rebelión y conspiración por
estos cargos el goberna ex gobernante
puede ser relacionado con penas
privativas de la libertad no menor de
diez ni mayor de veinte años la fiscalía
también ha tenido una noche larga hizo
un allanamiento en Palacio de Gobierno
como parte de estas investigaciones y se
alista a pedir o mejor dicho a solicitar
a la justicia peruana un pedido de
prisión preventiva contra el mandato ex
mandatario Pedro Castillo